after my set I was
I was uh just like behind the DJ booth
watching Dylan do his and and I saw
drewski to the left table to the left so
I was like yo did you see drusky is down
there and the dude Alex my guy like that
handles all the wind stuff he was like
yeah they're with the milk boys and I
was like oh [__] maybe I'll go say hi
and there's like he's like cool I'll
take you down there so he takes me down
and I'm like
and I can't remember when this last
happened
it was uh oh when I told you about the
Jaden thing when I saw Jaden at that bar
yeah same exact thing happen I'm going
down and I'm like I see I see Kyle and
I'm gonna go and then this big ass
security guard steps in front of me he's
like yo
what are you doing and I was like oh
sorry I'm just gonna say hi and he's
like yeah sure you are
I'm like [__] he's like what's your name
I'm like how come Cody and like Alex was
like he just DJ and he was just up there
he's friends with him
and he was like okay yeah sure you are
and then he had to ask somebody to ask
somebody and this the whole situation I
just felt like a piece of [__] yeah I
was like God damn it this guy was
massive too yeah of course
and then and then eventually they're
like oh yeah yeah cool you can come in
and I went and said hi and it was just
kind of weird and then
I left yeah and that was that yeah nice
I was like I should have never done that
yeah it's all right now as long if
you're anti-social you never run into
those situations yeah no that's true you
never get stopped by a bodyguard ever so
that's the benefit of staying home or
you just
stand and stare at people yeah
like you finished DJing you just about
face from your position on the decks and
you just stand by the decks you just
stare at everyone
yeah that's pretty much what I was doing
anyways yeah honestly like
I was there alone too so I was just
you're like sick yeah didn't know any
anybody I think in that situation you
gotta Double Down pull out an iPad
and play uh
um paper clip simulator paperclip
simulator this is when the Apple vision
is gonna be the best yeah it's in
situations like that oh dude standing
alone no friends behind a DJ booth oh we
gotta we gotta go into that because the
outside is over yeah outside this is
this is the plan yeah they're gonna
stuff us all inside
outside is only for the elite elite and
the rest of us will be in
you know like your net worth is gonna
have to be 40 million to go back outside
yeah once these are in everyone's hands
we are uh it's ready player one [__]
they're gonna raise rent to ten thousand
dollars a square foot yep and it's gonna
be six of us living in former U-Haul
vans in our Apple Visions like just
plugged into an Amazon tube with the
noise can't let the airpod Maxes yeah
and just Amazon Burger
and we're all just watching the keynote
where he announces the vision over and
over and over again yep
it is actually over though which kind of
sucks yeah outside is completely like
this is the [__] it's over this is the
future it sucks yep
I so badly want to get one of these but
then you see pictures of it and you're
like
it sucks that like at least the iPhone
was cool like when they announced it it
was like oh holding it feels cool the
device looks cool doing this looks cool
yep one second yeah you can slow
cigarette and be on the phone it looks
cool yeah you're right texting looks
cool
yeah this sorry not look cool
what's up that's stupid sorry I'm just
taking a call isn't it stupid I can't
hear you I'm taking a call yeah see
that's cool as [__]
look at him
cool as hell
what's up [__] hit me yeah see like
awesome imagine him saying that in that
in my space goggles what's up [__]
what's up [__] face
yeah yeah yeah that was kind of cool
what's up [__] face no still kind of
cool what's up you know what it is about
this is it the eyes it looks like drunk
goggles yeah yeah
all these pictures the eyes are like
sort of refractable so they look so
stupid yeah agree hard you can't realize
either you know that right what like
it's an OLED screen showing a picture of
eyes it's not a see-through it doesn't
have pass-through it has pass-through of
like cameras but it's like if you winked
no one would see you right correct I
guess
yeah
I guess that makes sense
it's just weird let me just say this I
really despise all the
marketing and sales people and uh shitty
startup people that are getting in this
being like it's gonna be amazing imagine
imagine you don't have a laptop and you
just put on your goggles and your email
and all this is right at your fingertips
like that's a [__] nightmare man yeah
that's horrible yeah you wake up and
you're like okay it's time and just
four messages yeah hey are you coming to
this meeting just sitting in your
apartment getting yelled at and binged
and all this visual [__] you're like
yeah the one thing that I do think is
really cool the one thing that I saw
that I was like damn is on a plane you
can like make it a movie theater and
just totally be in a separate like you
just erase the current environment that
you're in yeah and you are all of a
sudden in this private little movie
theater where you have noise canceling
and you can't see anything around you
but the movie that sounds sick but
imagine dude if you could just sit at
home and then go into a virtual airplane
where you go into a virtual movie
theater and you just never have to leave
and deal with the airport okay that's
true that is true and then yeah where
would you need to go when you can just
make yourself be there yeah and then you
virtually fly to Virtual Lisbon and you
have a virtual croissant yeah and then
you like lift up for a second you're
like Amazon burger and then you put back
but yeah the the projection of the uh
like the app selection screen
like nightmare I don't want to see my
[__] apps it's the worst it's the
worst part of the iPhone it's doing this
I'm sorry dude I'm sorry
them them showing people in business
class with these [__] with this head
this head device is such [__]
imagine three people in economy with
this [__] thing just gesturing dude
you me and an economy and just
yeah
the real just elbow to Elbow is that how
you do is that how you selection really
oh man
just [__] yeah yeah
I gotta take these off
just [__]
[Laughter]
sir
hi sir
sir hi sir hi sorry sir sir sir sir
wait wait sorry sorry what's up
oh right uh coffee or tea uh coffee
please yeah sure
[Laughter]
my name's Michael
how many credits uh I got you [__] this
rules
[__] you're hot how long you been
dancing
and then next to him
some business for me
yeah yeah yep yep yep
okay great so yeah we'll put an order uh
ten thousand pounds of concrete yeah
really excited to get this project
underway what no no no I'm just on a
flight is it are is the P are the people
next to me kind of loud
ah yeah I can't hold on let me pet oh
whoa
oh okay sorry a bit of a fun visual over
there
sorry
mommy sorry yeah my neighbors just a
little loud
anyway yeah so God you're [__] hot we
can go ahead and we can go we can go
ahead and wrap this up yeah
okay bye
sorry I just need to use the restroom
just a Plane full of [__] people just
virtually sucking and [__]
the dystopian future and then some lady
pushing a steel cart down
yeah yeah
ciao
hola